à l'occasion des prochaines élections
législatives
le centre d'information civique organise
une campagne contre l'abstention il
édite une affiche en couleurs que les
mères peuvent se procurer au centre
d'information civique au 242 bis
boulevard saint germain 75007 à paris le
téléphone 544 14 17
edmond maire secrétaire général de la
cfdt invité de l'autre journal la france
en dessous de zéro neige et verglas tous
azimuts et ça va continuer demain le
talent que morange six ans après
plusieurs familles demandent l'ouverture
du procès au garde des sceaux aide
personnalisée au logement
les premiers prêts explications de
jacques barrot secrétaire d'état au
logement
mais madame monsieur bonsoir le temps
toujours ce mot dit en hiver c'est notre
sujet de conversation numéro un ce sera
donc la première page de ce journal
neige et verglas partout en france avec
juste une petite poche de résistance
dans le sud ouest les landes le pays
basque il bordelais sont épargnés mais
c'est la pluie qui a là bas pris le
relais partout ailleurs ciel blanc un
saule blanc une seule couleur en effet
pour la france uniformité aussi pour la
température elle est partout en dessous
de zéro conséquence principale
le verglas a envahi les routes depuis
hier la circulation est devenue
aléatoire dont plus de la moitié du pays
où il a fallu mettre en oeuvre tous les
engins et tous les moyens disponibles
pour limiter les risques d'embouteillage
et d'accidents graves otages sablage et
salage des chaussées n'ont pu empêcher
d'importants ralentissements surtout aux
abords des grandes villes et notamment
de la capitale accrochage innombrables
et dérapages mais peu d'accidents graves
un mort cependant un cheminot décapité
par un train près de paris il n'avait
pas entendu le bruit du convoi étouffée
par la neige des villages isolés surtout
en montagne comme ici vallorcine
ravitailler par hélicoptères mais dans
l'ensemble la france fait bonne
contenance devant la rigueur du temps
il faut dire que l'aéroport du bourget a
été fermé ce matin et la neige a été la
cause indirecte de deux morts à paris
pour la première fois même dans la
capitale deux lignes de métro aérien ont
été bloqués par des congères demain et
bien la météo persiste et signe toujours
du froid sur toutes les régions de
l'intérieur du pays avec alternance
d'éclaircies et d'averses de neige
une exception toutefois vous le voyez le
littoral méditerranéen
alors il est bien évident que devant
cette offensive de l'hiver de nombreux
citadins sont un petit peu désorienté
s'ils n'ont pas trop l'habitude de la
neige surtout à paris et c'est la raison
pour laquelle gérard mirego leur propose
ce soir un certain nombre de petits
conseils à suivre si possible ils
étaient nombreux ce matin les citadins à
redécouvrir les joies des transports en
commun ce qui leur manquait bien c'est
peut-être un bon hiver pour se remettre
en mémoire les petits trucs qui font que
quand on en a besoin
la sacro sainte voiture ne reste pas
inerte le long du trottoir que le
problème numéro un
de la voiture c'est la batterie le pour
le deuxième
je pense que c'est le la glace auxquels
il faut penser il faut penser à rajouter
du produit antigel sinon vous avez un
bocal qui est entièrement glace et vous
pouvez pas vous servir de votre la
classe ne pas oublier de mettre de
l'antigel dans le radiateur
ça arrive encore que des gens
aujourd'hui le maître de l'antigène oui
ça arrive encore malheureusement mais ça
arrive encore surtout aussi ne pas
oublier le faisceau d'allumage tout ce
qui est électrique sur la voiture c'est
le faisceau d'allumage qui l'hiver s'il
est un peu vieux prend l'humidité et
l'allumage se fait beaucoup moins
qu'avec un faisceau tout neuf nanti de
l'indispensable de rester malgré tout le
plus dur à faire démarrer
rouler en ligne droite est resté sur la
route nombreux ce soir sont les
rutilants carrosse qui hier encore avait
fière allure et qui se retrouve
maintenant tout froissé un peu comme si
la bonne fée bagnoles les avait
abandonnés principal sur la neige c'est
pour partir déjà accéléré surtout très
très doucement si vous avez une boîte
mécanique partir en première très
doucement et plus tôt en deuxième
semaine avec boîte automatique ça va
beaucoup mieux parce que la boîte en
train de nero doucement une fois que
vous êtes vous êtes partis surtout ne
jamais être année ou bien tout en
douceur pied léger en l'occurrence étant
synonyme d'efficacité
comme à chaque chose malheur est bon ce
soir les marchands de pneus cloutés
affiche une mine sereine
cela faisait longtemps que les affaires
n'avaient été aussi prospère même les
habitants des villes sont obligés d'y
venir et ce matin la journée s'annonce
est bonne je pense aujourd'hui il y aura
encore davantage de demandes
c'est plus que les années précédentes je
pense oui effectivement cette année
c'est beaucoup plus prononcée qui sont
les gens du goût des plus actives pour
les gens qui vont un peu tous un peu
tout le monde
les gens qui doivent partir en vigueur
notamment bien sûr et puis même les gens
qu'ils ont à faire des petits trajets ou
autres sentent quand même le besoin de
monter les pneus goûter new york paris
aujourd'hui c'était new york les
téléspectateurs amateurs de cataclysmes
météorologiques s'ils croyaient dans les
jardins du louvre les promeneurs
découragés par le froid se sont peu
montrées seuls les statuts sont restés
au même place normal ça date est déjà
reparti de paris ne sera pas resté plus
de 24 heures en france le temps tout de
même de voir deux fois le prix en mains
publiques et de rencontrer les
journalistes le président égyptien a dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas venus demander des
armes à la france et s'est déclaré
satisfait de l'ensemble de sa tournée
aux états unis et en europe
il reste tout de même toujours
pessimistes quant à l'avenir du proche
orient écrit ce qu'il a répondu à paul
nahon qui lui demandait s'il
n'envisageait pas de recevoir à nouveau
menahem begin ou de se rendre encore une
fois en israël
i'm still normes de l'arnoult pleine
forme depuis la vague lui dit 26 titres
soit là et mes tweets the president kl2
congrès 117 lui a valu d'être mr
arterton à albi returning to nigeria
chat between egypte en israël en août il
a mean devenu chine et empilées bridge
blanche
amine anti-lgv égale between assises
brigite aragon 5 2 est née à 19 heures
music for me or pour le vous êtes tombé
sur b avant son retour en egypte il
restait une dernière étape anouar al
sadate
rome le président égyptien il ya
rencontré il ya quelques minutes le parc
paul si ce dernier sujet en provenance
de l'étranger la situation dans ce que
l'on appelle la corne de l'afrique
c'est-à-dire tout cet ensemble qui
comprend 10 beauty vous le voyez
d'ailleurs moi la somalie et l'ethiopie
dans l'ogaden la situation est vraiment
dramatique grâce à la contre offensive
éthiopienne la somalie a officiellement
déclaré l'état de guerre sur toutes les
routes dans tous les villages de somalie
se forme de pillière des colonnes
d'hommes et de femmes
après une formation du ter accéléré
seront envoyés sur le front face aux
soldats éthiopiens
il y a 6 mois le front de libération de
l'ogaden soutenu par mogadiscio avait
réussi à chasser les éthiopiens de
l'ogaden territoire revendiqué par la
somalie depuis près de 17 ans cette
occupation de l'ogaden avait été la
cause d'un renversement d'alliance dans
la corne de l'afrique où l'urss
abandonnant la somalie choisissez comme
nouvel allié dans la région
les tubes se réorganise équipés avec du
matériel ultramoderne et surtout
encadrer par des conseillers soviétiques
et cubains les éthiopiens commence donc
une contre offensive qui remportent des
succès à la suite de sa rupture avec
l'union soviétique la somalie réclamé
aux occidentaux une aide militaire
conséquente est pour l'instant celle ci
tarde à venir n'épousant pas la ps2
mogadishu sur la légitimité de son
intervention dans l'ogaden les
occidentaux prudent ne veulent pas
mettre le doigt dans un engrenage qui
risque de faire éclater ce baril de
poudre qu'est la corne de l'afrique
le talc morhange maintenant un mot qui
fait toujours mal à la mémoire c'était
il ya six ans 36 morts 36 bébés décédés
à cause d'une poudre est bien depuis six
ans à rien ne s'est passé pas de procès
public
une longue instruction parsemé de
bataille d'experts de contre experts la
plupart des familles ont accepté une
transaction directe avec le laboratoire
responsable mais il reste une poignée de
parents en colère qui réclament le
procès c'est à dire la condamnation
publique des responsables et pour faire
accélérer la procédure
ils en appellent aujourd'hui au garde
des sceaux le 20 juin 1977
nous recevions une lettre de nos propres
avocats
disons à peu près ceci l'avocat de la
société gévaudan proposait de verser des
indemnités aux parents des familles
avant le procès et à cette époque le 20
juin
donc avant la fin de l'instruction nous
avons été franchement scandalisé parce
que nous ce que nous voulons c'est que
le procès ait lieu et que les
responsables de la mort de nos enfants
des blessures occasionnées à tous les
autres passent en justice et soient
punis sévèrement
il ne s'agit pas de nous donner des
dessous de table pour faire arrêter une
affaire qui a fait tant de scandales
pourtant d'autres familles commencent à
accepter oui beaucoup de familles ont
accepté de recevoir de l'argent avant et
nous sommes très peu nombreux maintenant
à essayer de tenir le coup et à vouloir
vraiment que le procès ait lieu
pourquoi ont elles accepté c'est que ça
va faire six ans bientôt que cette
affaire est en cours et les parents n'y
croit plus
il pensait même même pas que les parents
l'opinion publique
lorsqu'on parle dans la rue avec des
gens nous disent non ça n'aura pas lieu
vous n'aurez rien du tout ces types là
ne seront jamais punis ils les ont trop
d'argent et avec l'argent on peut tout
faire
il n'y a plus de justice les affaires
françaises maintenant avec d'abord ce
petit rappel qui n'est pas inutile
vous n'avez plus que deux jours pour
payer votre premier tiers provisionnel
il nous reste encore deux bonnes
semaines pour remplir votre déclaration
de revenus robert de le recevoir le
nouveau président de l'assemblée
permanente des chambres d'industrie de
commerce reçu aujourd'hui par valéry
giscard d'estaing à l'hélice reprise du
franc aujourd'hui à versailles le dollar
a reculé de 490 à 486 la monnaie
nationale se tient mieux à l'issue de la
réunion de versailles mais son
redressement est toujours en dents de
scie conseil interministériel
d'aménagement du territoire je ne rentre
pas dans les détails mais sachez qu'un
nouvel ensemble de mesures en faveur de
la montagne de la rénovation et de
l'aide spéciale rural a été adopté et
puis depuis quelques jours ceux qui
veulent acquérir leur logement peuvent
commencer à bénéficier des nouveaux
prêts instituée par la loi les aides
personnalisées au logement
ce week-end les offices publique d'achat
l'aiment bien que d'accord avec le
principe de la loi n'ont pas ménagé
leurs critiques et il nous a semblé
utile de faire le point avec jean
pellieux l'aide d'un exemple dans le
nord de la france a compris c'est dans
ce grand ensemble de cambrai qu'habitait
l'an dernier dans un trois pièces avec
leurs enfants
marie-andrée et christian laporte lui
est chauffeur routier elle ne travaille
pas il habite aujourd'hui une maison de
5 pièces à proville commune voisine
qu'ils ont acheté deux cent dix mille
francs à une société des hlm
elle est une des 17 du lotissement avoir
bénéficié dans le cadre de la réforme du
logement des premiers prêts d'accession
à la propriété des prêts accordés en
province par exemple jusqu'à 7000 francs
de revenus pour un salaire avec deux
enfants
ce prêt couvre 80% du prix de la maison
le reste après de l'entreprise où
travaille christian et un prêt de la
caisse d'epargne ainsi qu un faible
apport personnel 6 en france
exceptionnellement admis en dessous des
20% normalement exigés
le prêt à l'accession permet à cette
famille de toucher la nouvelle aide
personnalisée au logement apl qui sera
surtout sensible entre 2500 et 4000
francs dreux
nous avions mis un peu d'argent de côté
et nous pensions le le consacrer à
l'achat d'une maison ancienne
et puisque nous avons trouvé cette
formule très intéressantes toutes ses
économies nous avions fait mon mari et
moi nous a permis d'acheter des meubles
et de doubler la mise en chaque mois
vous versez combien pour rembourser les
mensualités 3380 francs wiki auxquels
viennent se déduire l'aide au logement
personnalisés 272 francs par mois ce qui
vous fait d'aucun payer me sens me sens
contre quels sont vos ressources et 3600
francs par mois il ya ce cas représente
à peu près 30 % à 30 % de notre vous
étiez locataire avant oui vous avez
envoyé terre joly qu'est ce que ça fait
cette impression d'avoir un cinq-pièces
asseoir comment expliquer c'est quelque
chose qu'on ressent on s'est dit ce tout
ce que je vais faire cesser pour moi
pour mon mari mes enfants je pense que
tous ceux qui font bâtir doivent
ressentir la même chose que nous des
ouvriers qui qui arrivons à avoir eu une
maison des meubles à jardin et du
pouvoir y vivre vraiment très
agréablement
certains critiquent votre réforme c'est
le cas des offices hlm qui vous
reprochent de ne pas avoir de grands
projets en matière de logement disons de
projet social
ce que je dirais c'est que on en a
vraiment marre
par ces mots et expressions des projets
globaux
c'est ce qui nous a conduits au tour au
barreau concentration à la bureaucratie
ce qu' il faut faire c'est donner aux
français un peu la possibilité de
choisir de de s'orienter les uns vers
l'accession les autres vers locatif
pourquoi voulez vous qu'on écrive au
départ qu'on va faire tendre logements
locatifs
mais sitôt france est choisie sa cousine
pas qu'il y ait 20 mille logements
locatifs en moins 1978 hausse est trop
tôt pour faire le bilan de 78 ça va
dépendre de ce que feront les organismes
hlm a évidemment si bout de la réforme
aura peut-être moins de logements le
crédit
jacques barrot qui vient d'ailleurs de
s'en expliquer dans un livre qui sort
aujourd'hui les pierres de l'avenir
n'est d'ailleurs pas le seul ministre à
écrire jacques médecin lui aussi a écrit
ce livre le terreau de la liberté et
puisque je sors mon courrier de la
semaine solide de olivier germain-thomas
les rats capitaine georges durand la
journaliste à l'est républicain les
présidentielles n'ont pas lieu c'est de
la fiction bien sûr et puis les
élections en france et un livre assez
didactique de marie thérèse lancelot et
de alain lance avec nous et nos mères
qui lui n'a pas écrit deux livres
je vais vous demander monsieur le cp la
générale vous avez entendu georges séguy
qui hier soir vous vous engagez à vous
engager politiquement en vous demandant
de vous inscrire aussi au ps elle reste
celui son conseil et georges séguy me
demandait plus précisément d'être comité
directeur à la direction du parti
socialiste alors très franchement il
n'en est pas question
à la cfdt nous sommes contre tout ce qui
peut créer la confusion entre les
syndicats les partis le double casquette
ça vous va pas nous sommes pour la
compatibilité des mandats politiques et
syndicaux ça nous semble beaucoup plus
claire pour distinguer syndicats d'un
côté par des gloses et puis je dirais
qu'il ya aussi assez de militants me
semble-t-il pour pouvoir fournir est
largement les organismes directeur des
parties d'un côté et des syndicats de
l'aude pour autant vous critiquer
l'attitude de georges séguy sa double
casquette précisément nous constatons
qu'elle crée la confusion bien souvent
et que elle fait apparaître par exemple
quand georges séguy prend la parole à
gentilly pour appeler à voter pour le
parti communiste il dit qu'il le fait en
tant que membre du bureau politique de
la cgt
mais comment est-il connu de l'opinion
comme responsable de la cgt c'est cela
une des confusions dont nous parlons et
nous pour ce soit clair pas de confusion
entre la responsabilité politique
responsabilités syndicales
alors vous réunissez assez souvent avec
la cgt pour établir un constat de
convergence entre vos plateformes
respectives est ce que vous allez rendre
public ce texte pour ne l'impressionnait
en plus unique celui de de la gauche
là encore nous ne souhaitons pas que
dans la période présente où le parti
communiste le parti socialiste et les
radicaux de gauche n'arrive pas à
s'entendre les syndicats donnent
l'impression de faire une sorte de
programme devront de gouvernement
remplacement
c'est pas notre rôle par contre nous
discutons avec la cgt pour faire mieux
qu'en mai 68 on mai 68 vous le savez à
cette énorme
mon social a eu des résultats certes
mais à notre avis insuffisant pour deux
raisons il n'y avait pas de politique d'
alternative de gauche unie à cette
époque et il n'y avait pas d'accord
entre les syndicats or cette fois-ci
nous voulons que s'il ya un gouvernement
de la gauche unie les syndicats est au
moins la cfdt la cgt et nous l'espérons
la fédération d'éducation nationale se
retrouvent ensemble avec des objectifs
prioritaires devant le gouvernement donc
nous discutons ensemble avec la cgt et
aussi avec nos camarades de la fen pour
éclairer nos priorités et le jour venu
quand nous sont dans une situation de
négociation alors très rapidement nous
ferons le maximum pour nous mettre
d'accord et présenter un visage uni
devant le gouvernement est aussi dans le
patronat c'est à dire que vous
demanderez un nouveau grenelle a très
certainement mais m'ont proposé quoi
parce que si si elle est partie gauche
vous donne la cinquième semaine de
congés payés le smic à 2004 et
nationalisation qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez demander en plus m'écouter
nous ne sommes pas là pour simplement
applaudir à ce que font les partis de
gauche les travailleurs que nous
représentons syndicalement souhaitent
que leurs organisations syndicales fasse
entendre toutes leurs voix soient au
coeur des changements et très
franchement nous croyons que nous avons
des compétences uniques aux naissances
par exemple sur les droits des
travailleurs sur les conditions de
travail sur les grilles de qualification
sur le statut du personnel sur la durée
du travail que non pas des partis
politiques qu'ils ne peuvent pas avoir
que n'a pas dans le détail un
gouvernement de gauche il ya donc des
grandes orientations du programme commun
de gouvernement mais il y a toute une
connaissance du milieu syndical avec les
travailleurs avec lesquels on discute
tous les jours de ces questions qui font
que nous aurons à débattre
nous espérons bien nous mettre d'accord
mais nous aurons à débattre et nous
entendons bien être entendu ne pas être
simplement des assistantes sociales d'un
gouvernement s'est dit cependant
l'hypothèse à l'histoire la gauche si la
majorité l'emporté ce qu'il y aura un
troisième tour social un bref un champ
vous allez vite oui encore faut-il que
la gauche l'emportent et de ce point de
vue nous souhaitons nous on
syndicalistes que cesse cette polémique
cet assaut entre les divers partis de
gauche qui ont ouvert une désescalade
que secret les conditions entre eux pour
refaire un accord
vous allez rencontrer n'ont pas fait
beaucoup de progrès depuis écoutez nous
souhaitons vivement notamment qu'ils
annoncent publiquement leur désistement
sans une automatique pour les 2e tour
nous voulons un gouvernement la gauche
unie nous savons bien que c'est une
condition pour le succès ceci dit si
malheureusement la majorité actuelle
doit être conduite nos revendications
resterait bien sûr en état et la grogne
sociale à 29 ans entrait franchement
nous ne pensons pas en termes le
troisième tour social
nous respectons les élections nous
respectons son résultat et l'action
syndicale à notre avis se développera
fortement parce que tout simplement il y
a des années que le couvercle est
vraiment appuyer à fond sur la marmite
et très franchement une grève comme
celle des vacataires de vtt à montrer ou
celle de michel a montré qu'il y a tout
un fond de mécontentement qui ne
s'exprime pas très fortement outre est
une façon prolongée parce qu'il ya un
espoir de changement politique
mais soyez sûr que si la majorité
devaient être conduites nous nous
inscrirons par la cfdt
sous le signe de la tente des élections
présidentielles de 1981 sous le signe
d'une nouvelle élection politique n'aura
serions dans une action syndicale pour
obtenir des résultats pour amener le
patronat et le gouvernement à négocier
réellement merger une toute dernière
question à vous poser je crois qu'on
voulait jamais posé ce que vous
accepteriez d'être ministre
un gouvernement de gauche écoutez les
camarades qui m'ont élu à la fonction du
slip ont certainement pensé que j'étais
utile et je crois très franchement que
j'y serai plus utile y compris pour agir
sur un futur ministre
et pour faire en sorte que l' influence
des travailleurs soient efficaces
quelques ce ministre en tiennent compte
je crois que je serais plus utile là où
je suis qu'un gouvernement il ya pour ça
des gens qui se sont préparés dans la
vie politique a exercé des
responsabilités gouvernementales
je suis formé à la vie syndicale ça
grand syndicaliste responsable chacun
son métier
je n'ai pas terminé avec les réseaux
social car il faut faire le point sur ce
qui se passe ça manufrance de dire à
saint-etienne on va de rebondissement en
rebondissement hier le nouveau pdg est
nommé il ya à peine une semaine à
démissionner à son tour il dit ne pas
avoir de renseignement satisfaisant sur
les investisse rappel de la faire par
pierre mike aviles manufrance c'est une
vieille histoire
pendant des décennies la vieille dame de
saint-etienne s'était distingué par la
variété de son célèbre catalogue est la
solidité de ses fabrications
mais aujourd'hui tout le monde le sait
ça va très mal à saint-etienne plus de
100 millions de pertes en 77
et puis la valse des responsables andré
fonvieille le dernier en date n'aura été
pdg qu'une semaine et vient de
démissionner c'était le cinquième
pourquoi quelle malédiction pèse donc
sur manu france et 6 33 mille articles
un plan de sauvetage existe mais il
manque toujours 60 millions pour
relancer l'entreprise capitaux publics
capitaux privés ou coopératif on peut
les trouver
mais du côté des investisseurs privés et
même des pouvoirs publics
il demeure comme une hésitation à
s'engager définitivement à l'hôtel de
ville la municipalité de gauche déclare
tout net ces hésitations là sont des
manoeuvres politiques
pas de chance pour manufrance le dernier
délai de survie donc juste avant les
élections le 28 février
ce jour là ou bien on a trouvé l'argent
ou bien c'est le dépôt de bilan
ce jour là on saura si la vieille
entreprise avec ses 3000 emplois
a pu triompher des hésitations de
l'argent la plainte de gérard furnon
contre la cgt le pcf le déclarait
irrecevable un simple particulier du
tribunal ne peut entamer des poursuites
pour politisation de syndicats voilà qui
nous amène à la politique proprement
dite avec le grand rendez vous de la
journée l'événement politique de ce
début de semaine
raymond barre sur antenne 2 tout de
suite après le journal raymond barre
l'invité de notre spécial législatives
il est déjà arrivé vous le voyez face à
alain duhamel qui est là et jean pierre
elkabbach qu'on voit pas là mon bar qui
a tout à l'heure installé à l'hôtel
matignon le fond dead à l'expansion des
programmes de télévision victoire de la
liste de la majorité au deuxième tour de
l'élection municipale d'issy les
moulineaux près de paris l'équipe de
monsieur menant accroît son avance
rappel à paris de l'ambassadeur de
france au gabon monsieur maurice
delaunay avaient été mises en accusation
dans la sphère du vote des français à
l'étranger
voilà pour la politique vu de paris mais
vous savez qu'ici antenne 2 ont fait le
choix depuis deux mois maintenant
d'aller voir comment tout ça est perçu
de province et très vite on y découvre
que là bas les problèmes économiques les
problèmes concrets prennent le pas sur
les simples préoccupations politiques
c'est notamment le constat de claude
carey et de jacques drouin qui
reviennent des vosges de saint dié plus
précisément
l'an dernier la mairie alors socialiste
de saint guy a été reconquise par la
majorité aux présidentielles françois
mitterrand avait un peu plus de 50% des
voix et au législatif de 73,2 député rpr
qui ne se représente pas cette année
avait battu un socialiste avec 600 voix
d'avancé
cette fois les cinquante cinq mille
électeurs déodatien ont le choix entre
deux primaires
côté majorité roger souchal 50 ans
avocat rpr et ancien député gaulliste de
nancy démissionnaire en 70 lionel
stoléru 40 ans secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre du travail opère depuis le
20 janvier
sa candidature a provoqué ici quelques
remous côté rpr en inaugurant à
saint-dié la semaine du travail manuel
il se présente comme le candidat du bon
choix vont se jouer non pas dans toute
la france mais sur une trentaine ou une
quarantaine de circonscription charnière
où on ne sait pas entre la majorité et
l'opposition qui va gagner et j'ai
choisi délibérément une des
circonscriptions charnière une des plus
difficiles lorsque je pense que plus
haut notre responsabilité est bien plus
il faut avoir le courage de prendre des
risques
le leitmotiv de tous les candidats
l'emploi est d'abord la situation
dramatique de l'industrie textile qui
représente 40% de l'économie régionale
si les efforts de modernisation tpp ici
ou là des usines ferment des firmes
comme boussac se concentrent où vivre au
ralenti
presque toutes réduisent leurs horaires
de travail et licencient des employés
entreprises inadaptée traditionnel est
rongé par la concurrence
le manque de qualification de la
main-d'oeuvre l'exode rural l'isolément
post également des problèmes aux
agriculteurs parfois mis paysans de
montagne ouvriers que rencontrent ici
roger souchal dans sa circonscription
prends devant vous si je suis élu député
de cet arrondissement de cette
circonscription au moins une fois par an
je tiendrai une réunion avec les
conseils municipaux et au moins une fois
par an je tiendrai une réunion avec les
gens responsables de différentes
professions qui voudront bien venir
discuter avec moi
côté opposition christian pirée 32 ans
énarque économistes socialiste tendance
crs christian staff 38 ans professeur de
ce s militants du parti communiste
adjoint au maire d'une petite commune de
la circonscription candidat local donc
il mène lui aussi campagne contre le
chômage dans la circonscription
les communistes s'adresse aux
travailleurs un autre en obtenant le
langage de la vérité
le langage de la clarté la droite mène
avec sa politique d'austérité le pays à
la catastrophe
je pense que vous êtes bien placé pour
le savoir puisque travaillant dans une
entreprise qui fabriquait des
équipements sociaux et la france en inde
cette entreprise epernay et vous mener
une lutte depuis 400 jours les candidats
de gauche participent ensemble à une
manifestation des syndicats contre le
chômage de 1300 demandes d'emploi dans
cette circonscription où une vingtaine
d'entreprises ont fermé leurs portes en
cinq ans tant dans le textile que dans
l'industrie forestière et c'est ce même
thème que développe le candidat
socialiste chargé au comité directeur du
ps des petites et moyennes entreprises
en faisant campagne lui aussi auprès des
50 % d'électeurs ouvriers artisans de
cette circonscription
il faut une politique d'ensemble pour
les vosges il ne faut pas simplement une
politique au coup par coup
il faut repenser l'ensemble de
l'économie vosgienne et en liaison bien
sûr avec les solutions globales que le
socialiste propose et qui sont celles du
programme commun de gouvernement
les difficultés économiques domineront
donc le choix des électeurs et leur vote
pourrait aller à celui qui sera proposé
une politique d' équilibre entre
l'industrialisation donc l'emploi la
préservation d'un cadre de vie naturel
je pense même qu'il y a en tout neuf
candidats saint-dié dont une femme
radical de gauche brasse ce journal se
termine n'oubliez pas le premier
ministre à 20h30 et notre dernier
journal aux environs de 23 heures avec
patrick lecocq je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
l écoute de nos programmes c'est patrick
lecocq précisément qui sera demain ce
poste
et pour cause de dossiers de l'écran
jeunes bretons que après demain bonsoir